well everything is is very stupid right
now everything is stupid and everything
is gross and everyone is an idiot that
is you know that I think that when when
they write about this era of American
history in the history books that should
be the the subheading well not everyone
not if not everything it's just that's
just how it feels sometimes I'm sure
that you've you've felt it as well if
I'm being totally honest you know and I
hate to be such a downer but I think
that we are headed to a very bad place
in this country and I am worried about
that I'm or in all seriousness I'm
worried that people are going to start
dying soon and what we need from our
leaders what we need from the people in
charge right now no matter what party
they belong to is calm and clarity moral
certitude strength but we're not getting
that we aren't getting it from hardly
anyone on either side what we're getting
is demagoguery and tribalism and when
your leaders are all demagogues and
tribalists and when you live in an
intensely stupid time where stupidity is
rampant and when you live amidst moral
decay as we do then you're gonna get
civil unrest and violence and bloodshed
that's that's when you mix all those
factors together it's inevitable history
proves that it's inevitable you know
this isn't a game in when I talk about
this and and I say well I'm worried that
we're headed towards towards a civil
unrest I'm worried that we're headed
towards chaos you know and there are two
reactions that you often get from people
when you say that one is I you're being
a drama queen as it'll be fine
the other is for someone is for someone
to say okay well what Dom ready let's do
it
fine with me I think both reactions are
stupid which is I mean that's the theme
here is stupidity if you say okay I'm
ready let's do it that's fine
I don't think you know what you're
saying because you've been fat and
comfortable for far too long
you know you think this is all a game
you watch Netflix seven hours a day you
play video games and eat Doritos you you
aren't ready I mean this is all
entertainment to you the moment the crap
hits the fan I mean really hits it for
real this time I think your tough talk
will go out the window in an instant and
you'll see that this isn't a game the
problem is that it's so much that we see
it so much as a game right now when
we're all when when we're on the
internet we're watching TV we're hiding
behind screens were insulated but it's
not this is real as for the idea that
this is a dramatic we're not I'm not
trying to be dramatic I just think that
we all have this thing in the back of
our minds and I have it too I'll admit
where we look around and and we can see
that things are pretty bad and we can
see that they're getting worse
culturally speaking societally speaking
but we just assume that it'll all work
out in the end that when it comes down
to it it's not really gonna affect us
it's not gonna affect our family it's
not gonna come to our front door that
there's a certain line that will never
be crossed an imaginary line that we
that we think is there and we think well
it'll never go beyond that the real
civil unrest and chaos and so on we
think it's something that's that's that
can't happen here it happens over there
it happens in other parts of the world
happens in other eras in history but not
here not right now we're immune to it we
think and we tend to think that way
instinctively because that's the reality
we've known so far to this point and as
human beings we will always assume that
past reality will be future reality we
always assume it past reality is future
real now when we say past we mean our
own past the things that we've
experienced personally we just take it
for granted humans also always struggle
to take a historical view of present
to look at things with a wider lens but
the truth is look you know rome fell
civilizations fall they fall all the
time that also is inevitable it will
happen eventually every civilization
will fall ours will one way or another
eventually but I think we are speeding
up the process right now so again what
we need from our leaders is clarity and
calm and resolve I don't say weakness I
don't even say moderation to depending
on what you mean by the word I certainly
don't mean that what we need are a bunch
of political moderates that's not what I
mean I just mean that we need something
other than tribalistic demagoguery from
our leaders and from ourselves from from
each other I mean in in general we need
something other than tribalistic
demagoguery but that's always seem to
get from anyone anymore and it's not
because when I say that our leaders you
know in DC are all a bunch of
tribalistic demagogues it's not I don't
mean that there are a bunch of
supervillains and that's some of them
kind of are but but that's not
necessarily why a politician would be a
tribalistic demagogue it's your
tribalistic demagogue because it's easy
and it's politically useful is just a
very eat it's easy to be that way and it
can be politically useful and it's also
dangerous weak self-centered people will
always choose the easy and politically
useful route and we've been electing a
lot of weak and self-centered people
which is why it does in the end always
come back to us we can't we can't blame
this all on you know the elites and the
the politicians and all these groups
that it's easy to blame
I mean who puts them there we're
electing these people so every time you
turn on the news and you see these
absolute idiots embarrassing themselves
and the country remember we put them
there we I mean with whoever's there we
put them we elected whoever it is and
whatever position they're in if it's an
elected office
we chose them alright so that's my
that's my doomsday ramble to kick things
off today just just some general
thoughts to ponder and and hopefully I
just need to put a little smile on your
face and give you some hope this this
afternoon I want to speak more
specifically and I'm gonna start by
mentioning this again because it's it's
so important I know I've been hammering
on this this week and last week recently
I've been hammering it but that's
because the media is ignoring it people
are ignoring it
politicians are ignoring it so I'm gonna
try to compensate in my own small way by
harping on it as you've heard from me
over the weekend a deeply entrenched
member of an tyfa staged a terrorist
attack at a nice facility the Democrats
have not condemned this just like they
didn't condemn the antifa riot a few
weeks ago where they assaulted a
journalist put him in the hospital with
a brain bleed
and then attacked other people with with
wrenches and/or with lead pipes and and
crowbars they didn't they didn't condemn
that either they didn't denounce it they
didn't say anything
it's the same with this and when I say
Democrats haven't denounced it I mean
none of them have none they're all
ignoring it they're all sitting back
it's it's it's amazing now I guess I
have to allow for the possibility that a
few maybe one or two have said something
I don't know why it's not like I've
personally pulled every single Democrat
elected fish official in the country but
the vast majority have not I haven't
heard any denunciations from any of them
so by a large it's been total silence
and when I say it's actually not silence
and this is one point I wanted to make
and bring this up I've been saying that
oh the Democrats are silent about this
that that that gives them too much
credit it would it would be better if
they were silent silence is better than
what we're getting best thing would be
if they stood up showed some showed some
moral clarity some leadership some
strength and stood up and said no this
is wrong we can't do this try to calm
the angry hordes that would be the best
they're not doing that silence would
you know really second-best all those
although very shameful it's that it's
not even silence it's it's it's worse
than that
because what we're actually getting is
demagoguery from the left from Democrats
demagoguery that implicitly encourages
and maybe even explicitly encourages
anting in some cases explicitly
encourages them but encourages them
either way
so aoc says that iced ice centers are
concentration camps you know that's
that's demagoguery
that's tribalistic and it's dangerous
because you say can't there are
consequences to colleges to that kind of
rhetoric that kind of language when
you're a person of influence when you're
in a position of leadership god help us
and you say stuff like that and you know
that there are radical militants on your
side who are big fans of yours how are
they going to interpret that you said
it's a concentration camp I mean if it
actually were a concentration camp then
people would be perfectly justified in
waging a violent assault on it to
liberate the captives if there actually
were real concentration yet in this
country then you'd be totally morally
justified in in in violence to shut it
down but of course there aren't
concentration camps and that is not a
concentration camp but when you say that
and people believe you
you are implicitly encouraging them to
treat it like a concentration camp and
so that's what this anti-fur guy did he
went there and that's all he did he went
with a gun and explosive devices and he
treated it like a concentration camp he
reacted the way a normal person would if
there was a concentration camp the only
thing that made it abnormal and wrong is
that it wasn't actually a concentration
camp
so she's encouraging it without saying
it explicitly she's encouraging the
violence this is what I'm talking about
when you say that their concentration
camp so you say they're all a bunch of
racist bigots who want to enslave you
America's fundamentally racist this is
The Handmaid's Tale women are persecuted
they want to take us back to the you
know the 1950s they want a blah blah
blah when you say that you're
encouraging the militants on your side
if you don't mean to encourage them then
win the militants act like militants and
they take your words literally and they
respond violently as they have been
doing you would at that point speak up
and say no no no that's not what I want
let me let me rephrase let me let me
clarify here I don't want you to do this
and you'll adjust your rhetoric
accordingly you'll look and you'll say
oh my gosh you know I called it a
concentration camp yeah it was hyperbole
I was trying to make a point now that
they're doing this let me stand up and
say listen guys it's not I'm totally
opposed to what they're doing act for x
y&z reason but but it's not a
concentration camp okay let me let me
let me step back from that if you didn't
want violence if you didn't want chaos
and civil unrest that's what you would
do that's not what the Democrats are
doing instead they are continuing with
the rhetoric they are escalating their
rhetoric as the violence esker escalates
and so what other conclusion can I draw
then that they want this okay so
meanwhile if I'm if I'm here talking
denouncing tribalistic demagoguery then
I'm not going to engage in it myself so
let's let's look at the other side as
well over on the Republican side we have
as I'm sure I don't even need to play it
you've already seen it all over the
place a million times just in the last
few hours but I will anyway so on the
other side we have this moment at a
trump rally last night a moment that is
getting shall we say a lot of attention
watch this and obviously and importantly
Omar has a history of launching vicious
anti-semitic
screen
[Applause]
okay let me say first of all just to
begin with it is obviously hypocritical
of the media to give this kind of stuff
so much attention while ignoring
completely ignoring and Tifa terror
attacks and Tifa assaults on journalists
all of which are of course are much more
dangerous much more newsworthy than a
chant at a rally so I the Conservatives
that are making that point I agree yes
of course at the same time though
putting that aside I mean it's it's
really easy and you'll notice a lot of
conservatives do this a lot of
conservative media people do this it's
the game they play where you know
something like this happens they don't
like it like something like this chant
they don't like it personally they
disagree with it they may even be
repulsed by it but they don't want to
say that because they don't want to risk
alienating their audience it's always
gonna be easier in these tribalistic
times to just stay tribalistic at all
times to stay on the tribal line at all
times that's always going to be the
easiest path simply the safest for you
it's going to ensure the best ratings
the most clicks and so on so the game
from conservatives is to is to just
something like that happens and it's
it's only it's oh the next day it's all
what about what about what about yeah
yeah that happened what about this what
about this what about this I have no
problem with the one about thing because
it's true that this stuff is happening
there are terror attacks and teef is a
terrorist organization this is all
happening too and we should be talking
about that and when you see the media
and you see Democrats trying to ignore
that and instead put all the emphasis on
something like this then we have to say
we have to we should point out that hold
on a second there's also this thing
going on over here we can't ignore this
I mean we can't let them set the
narrative we can't we can't just go
along with though we can't let them lead
the conversation so that's true but at
the same time we are cowards
if we do what they do and just
completely
ignore this kind of stuff on our own
side we're cowards and you know what
it's the worst kind of cowardice because
it's cowardice that dresses itself up as
sort of tough talk you know that kind of
thing because a lot of the conservative
cowards who want to ignore the stuff on
their own side they try they try to
position it as you know what I'm taking
the fight to the left I'm not gonna no
you're a coward and you know it
especially if you're in media you're a
total coward the reason you do your
doing it the reason you're ignoring it
is because you don't want to upset your
audience that's the only reason that is
the reason period any conservative media
person out there who ignores the the you
know problems on their own side the only
reason for it the only reason is because
they don't want to upset their audience
if they give you any other reason
they're lying they're cowards so as far
as that chant goes yeah it's obviously
wrong I mean it's wrong and repulsive
and gross Shh look Yohan Omar I I detest
her I I think she's a bad person I can't
I couldn't I I do not hold back at all
in criticizing Omar I'll put it that way
I think you know that I have spent many
many segments on this show talking about
all of the things that she's done and
said in fact just two days ago it played
a clip of her being asked about the
antifa thing refusing to say anything
kind of smiling and smirking I find that
detestable I find it disgusting I do
think this woman is anti-american I do
think she hates America I certainly
think she hates someone like me and
probably many of you watching right now
I do think she's a part of the problem
you want to about tribalistic demagogues
I mean she's like this is she's one of
the top offenders but she's an American
citizen so chanting sent her back is
just it's not only morally wrong it's
just so incredibly stupid you just
looks so dumb you look you look um
whatever you want to say you do look
like a dumb bigot when you say stuff
like you just look like a dumb bigot
that no one just no credibility nothing
to offer you look like an absolute [ __ ]
that's how it looks that's how it comes
across and I mean is it actually racist
to say that I mean no it's it's the word
racist has a certain meaning it's not
technically racist if you say send
someone back they're different it's not
technically it's a it is a it's a it's a
morally disgusting thing but it's not
technically racist but you certainly are
gonna come off like a racist and as I
said a few days ago this is not a
winning conversation to start parsing
and splitting hairs say well it's not
technically racist I mean racism is this
and I mean that's bad but it's not
racist I mean racist is this that's
raising it's similar it's racism
adjacent but it's not quite right losing
conversation she is an American citizen
so calling for her to be sent to another
country is Israel now it also is true
that that it seems very likely that
she's guilty of defrauding the
immigration system if that's the case
then she should be tried and convicted
and punished
we should stipulate though that the
accusation with the very credible
accusation Whitten there's been serious
reports surprisingly there's been
serious reporting done by those done on
this and the the accusation here the
credible accusation is that she
defrauded as I understand it she defraud
the immigration system allegedly to make
her brother in American says and not to
make herself she came here when she was
I don't know eight or nine years old so
I some people have justified this by
saying well look she defraud the
immigration system to become a citizen
so she's not a real citizen so she
should be deported even if that were
true she needs that's a crime she needs
to be convicted of it in a court of law
we don't just deport people because
they're accused of a crime I think we
can all agree
that even Ilhan Omar is is is entitled
to to due process well in fact I think
we probably can't all agree on that now
I think things have gotten so bad and so
tribalistic they're probably a lot of
people say I'll screw that senators you
didn't get due process she doesn't like
the Constitution send her away I think
there are a lot of people actually have
that attitude now but in reality she is
she does have the benefit of due process
but in any case the claim is not that
she herself became a citizen through the
fraud it's that she helps someone else
become a citizen now I don't know what
the can you lose your own citizenship
for doing that I don't know but that's
you gotta be tried and convicted and
then the punishment comes calling for
someone to be just some merrily deported
because you don't like them is wrong and
we should also say as a sort of
secondary consideration it is
politically disastrous it just is the
the image the sound that footage of a
bunch of white people at a trump rallies
shouts shouting send her back in
reference to a minority woman I mean
it's just like I said about the Trump -
it's you can say all you want that you
don't have a problem with it you can
justify it you can say it's not racist
you can say whatever you can give
whatever justification you want I don't
agree with them but you can give it does
it in the when it comes to a political
conversation there's really no debate
here that is politically bad and they're
amazingly there are people who even I
was having this argument on Twitter
today there were people Trump fans
saying oh no I think it's politically
good I think it's gonna help us really
you think it's gonna help us do you
think you think there are people who are
not committed right-wingers who are
gonna be more inclined to vote for Trump
because they saw a bunch of people under
Trump rallies saying send her back about
a minority one you think there are
people you think there are non-committed
right-wingers so we're gonna be more
inclined because of that you're you're
you're insane if you say that you don't
you have absolutely no understanding of
our culture and the way the way things
are right now
you certainly especially don't
understand voting demographics let me
tell you something
Donald Trump won in 2016 because he want
Pennsylvania and Michigan and he won
Pennsylvania and Michigan because
Hillary Clinton had depressed turnouts
in places like Philadelphia in Detroit
those voters didn't show up in large
numbers like they needed to for her to
win those states if in 2020 there are
massive turnouts in those urban centers
especially places like Philly and
Detroit Trump will lose the math doesn't
you could say all you want he won in
2016 you said this in 2016 you're wrong
okay great it's not 2016 anymore the
math just doesn't work it's there's this
is this isn't magic here if she gets
huge turnouts in these big cities in
these kind of in these would have become
swing states I suppose now he'll lose it
there aren't enough other voters to
compensate so it's a mathematical
reality you can't get around it and
stuff like this these kinds of moments
those are going to be put in ads they're
gonna be played ad nauseam over and over
and over again at places like
Philadelphia and Detroit to get those
voters out that's why it's politically
designed it's morally wrong also
politically disastrous for that reason
because that is going to motivate those
urban voters to get out and vote against
this because they're going to believe
that not only Trump is racist but that
he is at the at the head of a racist
movement of people who want to deport
them from the country that's what
they're going to believe it doesn't
matter if it's not true Trump is making
it and his and the people that rally may
be very easy for his opponents to paint
that as the reality
all right I don't want to talk about
this Scarlett Johansson obviously a
left-wing Hollywood actress aren't they
all has are they all is there a single
is is there a we could think of us a few
conservative actors male actors and how
they would a few but are there any
conservative female actresses in
Hollywood that actually get roles I was
added maybe they're a couple like I
can't think of time ahead anyway so
left-wing Hollywood actress has gotten
in trouble with with the PC mob several
times in recent years she played a
character in a movie a while back that
was originally Asian in the source
material she was Asian so that was a
problem of course it's not a problem to
as we've gone over it's not a problem to
take a white character and turn them
into a different race you can make Ariel
black but to make changes the other way
that's a problem that's a huge outrage
that's not okay
those are the rules now just so you
understand and then she was going to
play a trans character in an upcoming
film but there was so much outrage about
that that she was forced to withdraw
from the role and finally in an
interview when asked about this stuff
she she actually decried the
PC I think she even used the word
political correctness and she says the
quote from her she says as an actor I
should be able to play any person or any
tree or any animal because that is my
job and the requirements of my job and
she's right of course exactly right but
she's faced major backlash now for those
comments and predictably of course and
now I think she issued some something
like an apology kind of retracting
backpedaling from that from that brief
moment of truth that escaped her lips
she's now saying oh never mind and this
is another example of the left eating
its own so we understand that but what
she's saying is true and that's why this
whole thing is so dumb because number
one it's it's acting you're pretending
to be something that you're not
that's what acting is that's why we we
can award actors and say oh this person
did an especially good job of acting
doing an especially good job of acting
the reason we can say it's a good job of
acting is that what what we're really
saying is this person did a really good
job of pretending to be something that
they're not so what acting is the other
issue is that we talk about
representation in Hollywood and that's a
big deal now that we need all these
different groups represented they need
to be represented okay
well if you're talking about trans
representation in Hollywood how how many
trans people exist in the country it's a
it's a it's a very small percentage one
percent I mean less than that so if
there are only a few trans people in the
country in existence and then there are
only few trans people in Hollywood well
dad that right there is proper
representation in fact there have been
studies done on this and I don't have
them in front of me but there been
studies done showing that if you break
things down demographically by race and
all that stuff you'll find that everyone
is pretty well represented in a Leawood
in fact many times the minorities are
over-represented because it wouldn't be
it's not like if you if you've got you
know the 50% of white actors getting
roles the 50% of black actors getting
real the 50/50 that's that is that is a
disproportionate representation so if by
representation you just mean that things
should be equal in terms of their
percentage and that you know in in
society and that should be reflected in
Hollywood well then we're pretty much
that's where we are so there's no
problem here and anyway there wouldn't
be a prop even if it you know if it was
if it was 98 percent of a certain race
getting jobs and 2% or if it's 50/50 or
if it's 75 whatever the percentage is it
doesn't that doesn't matter because it
should be whoever's best for the role
gets the job whoever is best at doing it
should get the job matter what their
race is it doesn't matter this isn't a
competition
and here is the other thing last thing
that strikes me especially when it comes
to this issue of trans people and you
hear that well
trans people should play trans
characters which has we've already gone
over is very stupid because the whole
point is you're pretending to be
something you're not but but even beyond
that I thought isn't it ok if you're if
you are a quote trans woman which means
that you're a man identifying as a woman
which wouldn't you want to play women
just regular women in a role isn't the
whole your claim here is that you're a
woman just like any other woman so to me
it just strikes me as oddly unwove for
the Liberals to be saying well trans
people should play trans characters
aren't you shouldn't you be saying that
trans people should play non trans
characters because trans women are women
so should they should just play women
isn't that your perspective it's just
your what you're calling for he doesn't
even make any sense based on what you
usually say so that that to me it just
doesn't it doesn't make any sense but
this is what you get from identity
politics is is a lot of nonsense alright
last thing I want to mention before
emails and I I just saw the headline
here so I'm looking at the article now
we will experience this together for the
first time this is in the Daily wire
it's as a from Paul Bois a feminist
student specializing in 3d design and
craft from the University of Brighton
has ushered mankind into a new era of
sexual equality by designing a chair
that prevents man spreading so it's a
chairs report from the Daily Mail says a
university student has won a national
award for she won an award for it oh my
gosh
a National Design Awards you won for
this for a chair that stops men from
manspreading Leila Laurel created the
piece of furniture to stop men from
widening their legs and encroaching on
other people's space the chair does
nothing revolutionary simply positions
two pieces of wood so that the man
sitting down must keep his legs together
and then there's also an I believe
there's also another chair so there's a
there's a chair for men that yes
squishes their legs together and there's
also a chair for women that encourages
them to spread their legs so that
they're the ones now manspreading or
woman spreading I guess the whole thing
is completely stupid you know what it
come feminists are complaining about
stupid things all the time obviously and
so it's hard to point to one particular
thing and say well this is the dumbest
thing that feminists have complained
about but man spreading that really
might be the dumbest feminist complaint
of all of them and that is saying quite
a lot that really might be the the the
of all the claims of persecution this
one is the most erroneous and fallacious
and ridiculous yeah I know that
feminists and if you're a feminist that
somehow is listening right now listen I
understand I know that you struggle with
subjects like biology and Anatomy not to
mention logic and and and and everything
else but especially biology and Anatomy
as a member of the left wing and you
understand you struggle with that you
don't have a lot of understanding so let
me without being graphic I'm going it so
I'm gonna try to put this delicately
delicately without getting into too much
detail but you see that there is a there
is an anatomical reason why men will
spread their legs when they sit down
there's an anatomical reason why men
don't sit with their legs push together
I you know you you could look it up if
you need more information maybe take a
look at a biology textbook you probably
don't want to find one that was written
before say five years ago because who
knows what those things say now that
nowadays but look at it look at a
trustworthy by a lot biology reference
and maybe you'll understand but there is
so yeah it's actually not a patriarchal
conspiracy when men are sitting on the
subway with their legs spread
they actually they're not trying to hurt
your feelings it's not the patriarchy
it's not it's not even though this might
be shocking for you it's actually not
about you at all I know that's
surprising so pick yourself up off the
floor after hearing that but it's it's
you see there are some things that you
as a feminist may be in but you don't
know and you don't know this but there
are some things that aren't about you
yeah
right so this is this is one of those
things it's not about you it's got
nothing to do with you they have their
legs spread more than you spread your
legs because they have anatomical
differences with you that make it so
that men have to sit differently
otherwise it's extremely uncomfortable
and actually unhealthy so that's all
that's all I'll say about that all right
Matt wall show at gmail.com is the email
address this is from I didn't get the
name of this person unfortunately this
is from someone says hey Matt I was
trying to come up with a definition for
a man or woman that would fit with the
transgender worldview I think would
require four definitions one man a
person who feels they are more masculine
than feminine woman a two woman a person
who feels they are more feminine than
masculine three masculine those traits
that tend to appear in people with a Y
chromosome for feminine those traits
that tend to appear in people with no Y
chromosome obviously these definitions
only work for the ideology that says
there are transgender people but only
two genders and not for the gender is a
social construct crew you may have
already argued with this argument and if
so I apologize yeah why so it's a
Herculean effort on your part to try to
come up with a with even if it's if it's
a wrong definition as you're aware I
know this isn't your definition you're
trying to help the left out here which
is very charitable of you but Herculean
effort to try to take their worldview
and see if you could come up with at
least a coherent definition for man and
woman that would be consistent with that
worldview
unfortunately it's it's just not
possible to do you're attempting to do
something that's impossible because
their worldview especially with respect
to gender is completely incoherent and
contradictory so there's no way to
define terms that won't end up being
coherent and incoherent and
contradictory the problem is you say
well okay this definition works for
someone who believes that transgenderism
is a thing but would also say that there
are two genders and genders and the
social construct the problem is though
that that group doesn't exist everyone
on the people who believe in
transgenderism are going to say that
gender is a social construct in fact
that is a that is an integral
part of their whole world views that
they think that it's fluid it's on a
spectrum which means that ideas like
masculine and feminine in that case
obviously cannot be defining for cannot
be objectively defining for for man and
woman because they would say that
masculine and feminine these concepts
are completely arbitrary total social
constructs we as a society we just
invented them out of whole cloth there's
no objective reason for them at all and
so therefore they're illusory and you
can't you can't tie them to a definition
of man's that's so that doesn't work for
them but good attempt though this is
from Greg says Mr Wolf's awesome
discussion of gender / sex on Wednesday
show I love your heuristic regarding
asking transgender advocates to define
what a man or woman actually is
brilliant this will henceforth be dubbed
the walsh protocol i like that
the wolf protocol i've always wanted to
have my name on a protocol and so or a
rule yeah so it walsh protocol or walsh
rule ID so i'm a fan of that the entire
because i'm a theocratic fascist of
course so that's why i'd be a fan of
that the entire topic essentially boils
down to warmed-over nominalism and shadi
post martin modern word games but if
gender is merely a social societal
construct as the radicals claim then we
can slash should probably discard the
idea of gender altogether after all once
a person's gender can be potato or
bicycle i think the concept that has
been the concept has been completely
divorced from reality and it has no
objective meaning yeah I think you're
right Greg and you're right to observe
that because that's kind of what had
what's happened here where this phony
distinction between gender and sex was
invented by the left whereas in reality
gender is really just a completely
linguistic concept it's got nothing to
do you know people don't have genders
really people have you you have a sex
you don't have a gender
and you certainly don't have a sex which
is distinct from your gender or agenda
which is distinct from yours X these are
at most these these are interchangeable
words but with the left try to do is
they try to create to them as two
completely separate concepts so that
people you know rather than words having
a gender you could have a masculine or
feminine word that's what it should be
but they try to take that linguistic
concept and put it on people and say
well now people have genders and sexes
and the two could be completely opposite
but what you're fine which which is
which is absurd clearly but I think what
they found is that well okay
they they don't want to say it used to
be okay well you've got a biological man
but his gender is woman because that's
what he identifies as which is which
sort of another way of saying that well
he's just he's a feminine man but they
don't want that what they want to say is
what what they're claiming now is no
it's a man who identifies as a woman is
a woman this this isn't there's no
distinction between a trans woman and a
woman these are two different these are
because they're the exact same thing so
now I think what they've done is they've
actually discarded the word the ID the
concept of gender themselves now because
now they're saying that sex is fluid sex
is a is on a spectrum biological sex is
on a spectrum it is fluid that's what
they're saying now so I think what they
did is they they introduced this concept
of gender you know in the beginning in
order to promote the whole idea that you
know of gender spectrums and everything
else the idea that you could transition
from one to the other
now that they've sort of implanted that
into the public consciousness a well we
don't really need this anymore it's it's
it's had its day it's done what we
needed it to do we don't need it anymore
we'll throw it out
all right this is from Jenny says hello
Matt hello Matt thank you for your work
the work you do I really enjoy your show
I'm curious if you know of any good
music that isn't Christian I get tired
of listening to the same songs over and
over again
I enjoy some of them but I would like
something different sometimes I recently
searched for clean pop music or
something like that the songs that came
up had no bad language and it wasn't
over sexualized however the meanings of
the songs were still horrible most of
the songs were just stupid why can't
there be quality music or am I missing
it I hope you can help well I think
there is a lot of quality music
unfortunately I can't really recommend
anything because gives you I guess if
you like pop music and that's what
you're looking for then I I don't listen
to that music myself pop music so I I
can't I don't know maybe someone else
can write in and give some
recommendations for pop music that's
actually good and not totally vulgar and
also not Christian I there's probably
not a lot of it I assume it probably
does exist I just can't I don't know I
don't listen to music but what I can say
generally speaking is that there is good
music today there are great bands out
there that are making really good
thoughtful interesting music they're not
Christian they're just just like there
are great movies I really hate it when I
hear from from from Christians there's
something Christians say a lot as it is
it's nothing but terrible movies these
days nothing but terrible shows nothing
but terrible music it's not true it's
there's a lot of great stuff there's a
lot of garbage yeah there's a lot of
great stuff a lot of great stuff you
know III think that I mean certainly
when it comes to TV shows that we're I
think everyone basically recognizes
we're in the Golden Age of TV shows and
there's there so many it's it's it's a
embarrassment of riches every year
there's another great just work of art
kind of television show that comes along
multiple in that category I think it's
the same with with movies or a you know
if you're looking for movies in the
theater the kind of big box office
smashes well they're all going to be
trite and redundant and and superficial
and all that but movies that go right to
streaming movies that maybe aren't in
theaters for very long there's a lot of
great
movies out I think that's kind of an
illusion where we think oh well you know
all the great music was in the 70s all
the great movies back in the day they
had all the good stuff well now that's
not really true it's just that we we
only remember the good stuff from the
70s in the 60s there was bad stuff - we
just don't remember it because it was
bad and so our view of it now is oh they
had nothing but classics but that's not
actually true so anyway that's a long
rambling way of saying that I I guess I
can't answer a question but I'm sure
there is good stuff I I know in general
it might not be Gianna as you general
isn't it but there is there are good
bands out there and I think it's I think
it's a good idea for Christians to
branch out and to not stay in that sort
of Christian entertainment box because
it really is ok you know to listen to a
song that's about something other than
God I mean it's great to listen to songs
about God don't get me wrong
but we're not required to only listen to
songs about God or Jesus or only
watching movies that are about cottages
and and really if it's a song about love
it's if it's if it's a song that touches
on anything true and real then in a
sense it is also about God though
indirectly all right finally let's see
this one's from John says I've been
reading and studying a lot about the
conquistador Hernan Cortes Cortes in
fact he's my favorite conquistador
obviously he's hated now and slandered
but I personally believe his bad
reputation is undeserved well we're
coming up on the 500th anniversary of
Cortes expedition November 8th 2019 will
be the 500th anniversary of the entrance
into Mexico by Cortes and his men I
think we should be celebrating Hernan
Cortes the civil rights activist in my
opinion he is the greatest civil rights
leader of all time he did after all stop
human sacrifice even if it did come at
the price of destroying a civilization
that's quite a qualifier so mr. Walsh I
hope you'll be celebrating Cortes day
500 celebrating the end of human
sacrifice and bringing the bringing of
the Catholic faith to a new land
yeah I I've talked about Cortes before I
think I read a book jeez I'm trying to
remember that
rich Richard Lee Marx I believe was the
author of a book book it's called Cortez
I thought was a great book I don't know
I stumbled across it at some used
bookstore not not a well-known book by
any means written I don't know written
10 20 years ago or something I thought
was a great book it's it's it's an
amazing story about Cortez that he was
able to come with his relatively small
band of of conquistadors and overthrow
an entire civilization and it certainly
was a violent process we can't we can't
make any we can't deny that it was very
violent especially with their final
sacking of the Aztec capital it was just
total bloodshed it was a massacre but we
should also say that your Cortes was
along the way as he was tangling with
the Aztecs he also made alliances with
other Indian tribes in the area who were
eager to ally to ally themselves with
with with Cortes because they hated the
Attucks because the Aztecs were
enslaving and pressing them the Aztecs
would come in and demand human
sacrifices I mean the Aztecs were coming
and stealing their children and their
their wives and ripping out their hearts
and consuming their limbs I mean this is
just court grotesque satanic stuff the
Aztecs as you mentioned human sacrifice
I mean they they sacrifice tens of
thousands of people there was one period
which I'm sure you're aware of a few
years before Cortes showed up we're in
in a in a period of three or four days
they sacrifice something like 80,000
human beings to christen a new temple
that have been built I mean think about
that 80,000 and when you when you
consider the process the way they did it
you put someone down on a stone slab you
rip out their heart while they're still
alive cut up their limbs roll them down
the temple steps and then at the bottom
oftentimes their limbs will be consumed
by the Aztec priests
horrifying it's it's difficult to
believe that this ever really happened
but it did
imagine 80 imagine just the pile of dead
bodies and limbs that must have been
there and that's something that the the
the Spanish found as they were getting
deeper and deeper into Aztec territory
they would stop at these temples and
they would find blood Drent blood all
over the place piles and piles of bodies
and skulls and bones horrific absolutely
horrific so as I was saying the these
these other tribes were eager to enter
into alliances with Cortes sometimes
they would fight Cortes first and then
be defeated and then realized that okay
maybe we should team up with him and the
reason they were eager is because they
said they were they were being oppressed
and enslaved so when they finally
entered the Aztec capital and there was
a total bloodshed and slaughter on a
massive scale much of that though
happened on the part of the other
Indians who were taking out their rage
on the Aztecs and so most of that
slaughter was sort of India non-indian
slaughter at least the indiscriminate
slaughter of civilians anyway that's a
long way of saying that I I agree with
you I think Cortes was obviously a
flawed man but a great man and he put an
end to one of the worst human rights
abuses the world has ever known and he
ultimately toppled possibly the most
savage civilization that has ever
existed that's not a racist term here
okay when I say savage I mean the
practice of cutting out the hearts of
tens of thousands of people than eating
their bodies that is savage in every
sense of the word I will then join you
in celebrating Cortese day 500 I'm on
board for that and we will leave it
there thanks everybody for watching
thanks for listening Godspeed hey
everybody its Andrew Clavin host of the
Andrew Clavin show Trump's crowds are
angry about
on Omar and they're chanting send her
back should we clutch our pearls thump
our chests thump our pearls clutch our
chests sounds like a porn film but we'll
figure it out
plus it's mailbag day on the Andrew
Clavin show